JESSE: THE STRUGGLES OF CNN.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF TONIGHT'S
WATTERS WORDS.
COMPETE AGAINST CNN.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
FOX NEWS NUMBER ONE, MSNBC
NUMBER TWO, AND CNN7.
IT'S BEING BEATEN BY HGTV AND
NICKELODEON.
HERE ARE THE STORIES CNN HAS
DECIDE OWN.
A MISSING PLANE.
>> WHETHER IT'S MECHANICAL OR
TERRORISM OR PILOT ERROR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING
ABOUT BLACK HOLES.
JESSE: A FIRED POSSIBLY TRUMP
HANGER-HONOR.
>> I SMELL ALCOHOL ON YOUR
BREATH.
>> I HAVE NOD NOT HAD A DRINK.
>> I NOW IT'S AWKWARD.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE QUESTIONS.
>> MY ANSWER NOISE, I HAVE NOT.
>> ANYTHING ELSE?
>> NO.
BESIDE MY MEDS.
ANTIDEPRESSANTS.
IS THAT OKAY?
>> I AM JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED.
JESSE: AND A PORN STAR.
>> THE STORMY DONE YALS HAVE THE
PRESIDENT'S NUMBER?
IT SURE SEEMS THAT WAY.
>> STORMY DANIELS.
>> THE RECENT HE CAN'T ENGAGE
WITH STORMY DANIELS IS BECAUSE
SHE HAS GOT HIS NUMBER.
JESSE: HOW DOES THAT SQUARE WITH
CNN'S NEW PROMO THAT CASTS THE
NETWORK AS A PARAGON OF
RELIABILITY.
>> SOME PEOPLE MIGHT TELL YOU
THIS IS A WHAT MANAGA.
THEY MIGHTD TELL YOU THIS IS A
BANANA.
THEY MIGHT EVEN PUT BANANA IN
ALL CAPS AND YOU MIGHT START TO
BELIEVE THIS IS A BANANA, BUT
IT'S NOT.
JESS.
WHAT ABOUT CNN'S FAKE VIDEO OF
TRUMP FEEDING FISH IN JAPAN OR
THE FAKE STORY ABOUT COMEY'S
TESTIMONY OR SCARAMUCCI AND THE
RUSSIANS WHICH WAS REDACTED AND
LED TO THREE PEOPLE RESIGNING.
CNN PRIME TIME HAS BECOME ALMOST
UNWATCHABLE.
HERE IS WHY.
>> PEOPLE ARE CARE ARE THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE SICK AND
TIRED OF HAVING THIS WHITE HOUSE
BASH THEM ON A DAILY BASIS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE MALIGNED --
>> THAT WAS AN EXCUSE.
LOOK AT EVEN HOW THEY GOT THE
PERMITS.
CAN I FINISH, SIMONE.
CAN YOU JUST SHUT UP.
>> YOU DON'T GET TO TELL ME TO
SHUT UP ON NATIONAL TELEVISION.
>> HE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THE LAW.
YOUR FRIEND IS A THUG.
THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS.
>> THUG THUG THUG THUG THUG.
>> YOU HATE IT.
THAT'S YOUR SUBSTANTIVE ARGUMENT
TO ME, RICK WILSON.
>> I WILL GUT YOU LIKE A FISH ON
THIS SHOW IF YOU WANT TO KEEP
THIS UP.
JESSE: THIS KIND OF MAYHEM
COMPLETELY UNDER CUTS THEIR
IDENTITY AS A STRAIGHT NEWS
NETWORK.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE
NETWORK IS FILLED WITH
TRUMP-HATING TABLOID FOOT FOODS.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME?
LOOK AT HOW MUCH TIME WAS
DEVOTED TO STORMY DANIELS
COMPARED TO THE SPENDING BILL.
THE SPENDING BILL HAS MUCH MORE
IMPACT ON AMERICANS.
BUT CNN IS TRYING TO HOLD
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION WHILE THEY